i've got two of my brothers here i don't
think you've ever met them before so be
careful because they're way smarter and
better looking than me but they got
questions for you as well i'll go first
kevin thanks for doing this and uh now
that we've clarified you've gone from
bitcoin being garbage to a significant
allocation we'll have to get you one of
these hats you're never gonna stop you
guys are never gonna let me go like
you're never gonna not bring it up again
like what i'm gonna like a hundred years
from now you're still gonna roll out
that tape yes yes well maybe but i
respect the fact that you you did the
work you changed your mind and you've
now allocated a significant portion
that's awesome so my question uh is is
pretty simple i think maybe complex uh
to some degree though which is we have a
lot of young people that watch this show
who are early on in their uh investing
career in their call it personal finance
journey right just getting things in
order investing some money allocating
some capital out of each paycheck etc
knowing what you know now if you had to
go back to your early twenties in the
current market environment how would you
think about uh kind of just starting out
investing
uh though i would have listened uh
earlier to the concept of
diversification because
you know i live by a rule now um it's
very simple i never let one position
become more than five percent of a
portfolio and no sector become more than
twenty and i consider crypto to be a
sector now i can invest in mining i can
i go coins i can do tokens i can do
bitcoin ethereum there's a lot of
different things so i consider it a
sector so technically for
diversification i could go to 20 in
crypto but bitcoin would never be more
than five percent of a mandate you see
what i'm saying a single asset and if i
were starting there's two things i would
do if i could talk to myself again
because i'm guilty of having bought a
lot of crap i didn't need when i was
young i wish i'd simply taken 10 percent
of my income when i started working and
that was like when i was 17 years old
and simply invested it
in into the market and it if crypto
existed then i would have put some in
there too but had i done that
i'd be
way better off
than where i was you know 15 years
because it was only
decades later that i figured out
investing and started to scramble i got
married i had no money and so i was able
to solve for it later on by taking some
chances but
investing from the beginning is the key
and that's that pair of jeans you don't
need or that crap you don't need and you
can always save 10 of your income and
just stick it into an investment long
term you'll be way better off makes
sense john
yeah kevin thanks for doing this nice to
meet you um i am curious about where you
see so you've come a long way like joe
said and anthony as well um where do you
see the regulatory environment and
discussions around bitcoin.
uh so example the etfs that have been
proposed have not been passed where do
you see the entire space
yeah it's a great question and everybody
i mean i'm i'm in that indexing market
as well and we have this conversation
every quarter
so as you know the canadian regulator
allowed both ethereum and bitcoin into
etfs and there's multiple offerings and
they've all been successful um and they
definitely uh are correlated to the
price of bitcoin and so you can trade
that volatility up in canada on the tsx
and it's and they're not the only
country that's going to allow that so
i'm optimistic that the u.s regulator
will follow suit at some point but not
next year there are multiple
applications waiting and the reason
they're going to go cautiously as a they
can and b they know when they make that
index when you actually can trade a
bitcoin etf that that will be incredibly
popular and in terms of just saying look
i want to trade the volatility of
bitcoin and i can't or i'm not allowed
to own the bitcoin for compliance
reasons but an etf is considered for
most compliance departments a compliant
equity so if you had an etf today it
would fit under the radar screen of many
institutions who could allocate
immediately to it and so that's why i
think the regulator is being very
cautious in terms of how they allow for
it my guesstimate and it's only a
personal estimate of what will happen is
we'll see this first in 2023 so it's
still a ways off but the interest in all
things crypto institutionally
is huge
and it's it's it goes back to what i
said earlier the the reason that you
haven't seen these allocations there's a
lot of excitement around bitcoin but the
truth is most institutions aren't
playing yet
is you simply don't have the
the compliance infrastructure linked
together yet you can't download an app
and put 100 million dollars into it
that's not going to happen you're going
to have to have so when i when i when i
buy a stock or a bond or or another
asset class for decades now compliance
has already
got structure
it's a mark to market on at four o'clock
at night
all the all the compliance
automatically occurs the positions are
known they're disclosed to the regulator
it's all done and that infrastructure's
been around forever we don't have that
infrastructure yet in crypto what would
be the sequence of events for an etf
approval in the us would they just say
hey
grayscale you get the approval or you
know uh uh one individual etf um
application gets approved or do they
have to from a market structure
standpoint approve three four five ten
of them all at once and they kind of let
the market decide how does that play out
i i you know i i would think they would
allow multiple competitors in the market
simultaneously all of the files have
been sitting you know with if you want
to call them shelf prospectuses for a
long time and so it's to say that one's
ahead of the other ahead of the queue i
don't think even exists anymore i don't
know that but it would make seem it
would make sense to me as opposed to
just give it to one issuer you know do
three or four bitcoin do three or four
ethereum maybe do uh you know maybe a
usd whatever has been filed for but
bring the market forward uh
simultaneously and let and let the
financial services compete because you
know look at it this way if somebody
said to me look you're going to have to
pay 80 basis points to maintain your
your bitcoin holdings inside an etf i
wouldn't do that that's crazy but if you
had three competitors maybe they go down
to you know sort of an index weighting
maybe 11 bips or 14 bips and i get
compliance and i get reporting okay
maybe that's worth it because i want
that right the great thing about an etf
is it's already on my statement on my
mandate and it's going to be compliant
and so i'm willing to pay something for
that but right now i'll tell you one of
the other problems in the in the crypto
industry is most of the
platforms i don't have to name names but
you know i know the same platforms you
do and i'm well aware of all the
initiatives going on
are not priced for institutional pricing
you can't charge an institution 300
basis points to maintain any crypto
anything they're not going to pay that
and so you've got to you've got to go to
scale
and you've got to get fees way down and
we don't have that yet most of the stuff
that's out there that's on your phone
has really a lot of friction in terms of
fees and they're just not going to pay
it so
there's lots of work to be done but the
good news is it's here to stay and the
amount and i keep saying this the
potential is it's just there's never
been an asset class with more potential
than this
i tend to agree uh you recently
announced a deal with ftx and i think
the reason why i like you so much is
when you go from
no to yes
you immediately say what do i bring to
the market that is unique and this deal
with ftx is really interesting because i
think it's an investment plus like an
ambassador or some sort of spokesman
type role explain kind of how the deal
works and what the thought process here
is
you know it was it was hap you know it
happened actually when we were together
in miami at bitcoin 2021. um i was
having meetings with most of the major
players in crypto at that time for
various reasons and i met sam
bankman-freed and he was a really
impressive guy and his team i met his
team after that and we started
starting to think a little bit about you
know
what's what's it going to take to get in
the same conversation we're having now
i was having with his team saying guys
what matters is compliance and you know
because we've we've talked a little bit
about me investing in ftx which i was
interested it's a private company
obviously but
i every day and i can't stress this
enough but sam understood this every day
i deal with compliance not some days
every day
tomorrow i have a two hour session my
quarterly session that i have no
um it's it's not is it you know can i go
or not go
i have to be there for two hours with my
compliance officers
otherwise i'm not compliant so you got
to understand
and i'm not the only person that goes
through this
i live and breathe compliance i was
explaining this to him he understood it
he was one of the first big crypto guys
that got the joke on compliance and the
more we talked about it the more i met
his team i realized
these guys
are institutional grade compliance
i can do something there that i can't do
anywhere else and be totally compliant
now it took
months to get my compliance people to to
figure it all out
but now
i can go into many different places in
crypto and 100 compliance with a heck of
a great team in ftx so i'm willing to be
ambassador and they you know they hire
tom brady too so i'm happy to work with
tom maybe i can play some football with
him i'm gonna show him how to pass you
know that kind of thing
[Laughter]
they pay you in dollars or in bitcoin or
something else
i i said to sam and his team when we
were negotiating this i said i do not
want any fiat currency i don't need any
more fiat currency what i want is all
crypto i want look i'm i'm getting
involved with you for compliance reasons
and you know i think i think sam liked
the idea that you know you've got a
spokesperson here that once was a
skeptic just like you keep poking me
pump all the time on this that has
turned around completely and now
endorses this but i have a different
mindset than the typical crypto advocate
you've heard me say compliance 400 times
since we started talking because i have
no other way to operate except to be
compliant the minute i'm offside
i am screwed so there is no option for
me to be outside and with ftx i can go
into this journey with a full compliance
infrastructure
these guys are big they're global they
have the technology to link they can
give you your mark to market they can do
all the things you need to stay
compliant and you can expand your crypto
holdings you're well aware of their
breadth yeah absolutely all right we're
gonna do a rapid fire and then i'll let
you go you you've uh you've withstood
our uh are poking over uh over your sins
of the past now that you've atoned for
them uh first one is what is the
breakdown percentage percentage-wise in
the portfolio between bitcoin and ether
yeah bitcoin's still the big daddy i
mean you know right now i've only got
three positions on by the end of next
month there'll be almost
uh
15 i won't disclose what those are but
right now it's primarily ether a little
litecoin um bitcoin and a ton of usdc
right but bitcoin is the biggest out of
those four it it's it still is because i
started putting on that weighting back
in uh
in 2017
and uh but you know i i must tell you i
i think
i don't think bitcoin only anymore
there's so much other there's so there's
there's so much other portfolio work to
do you're well aware of it i think what
we should do is every couple of months
you know maybe i'll get into the idea of
just disclosing what i own because
within a couple of months i'm probably
going to be at 17 positions i think that
once a month you should come on here and
we'll just ask you all the hard
questions anywhere in the world
i'm happy to do it i'm all about total
transparency and compliance and i'm just
you know people ask me what do i have in
dogecoin whatever this would have been
that you know
like for me
it's asset based
but
i am so intrigued with what we're doing
in d5 that's where the puck is going i
want more assets to do more defy with
because i think i can actually build an
income stream
when i start start talking about seven
percent waiting that's a lot of dough in
in my world that's a lot of you're rich
and you got it you're rich you know
well i know but it's it's
you know if if i make a mistake with one
or two percent
no hot dog for me if i blow seven
percent
i'm gonna cry like a baby so i'm gonna
think a lot about it all right what is
the thought process in terms of this
infrastructure bill all of the taxation
uh regulatory debate don't get into the
politics i don't care about the politics
but do you think that it's something
where the u.s basically ends up
embracing this or do you think the u.s
is adversarial toward over a long period
of time
no i think we're going to embrace it i'm
actually happy the deal didn't get
rushed through i'm in the camp that says
i'd rather have the policy match
the objectives of innovation and i think
the u.s should lead in crypto innovation
we should be developing the technology
some of the companies that you showed me
months and months ago are very
forward-thinking they need to work in
you know the stuff we looked at together
they need to work in a compliance
environment every single company that
wants to raise institutional capital has
to embrace the regulator and and i'm
waiting for it so i'd rather see policy
developed that you know does not if
you're a broker dealer and you're
trading assets you're you have to go
with a certain level of compliance based
on broker dealers that trade financial
assets but if you're a miner
and you're actually an infrastructure
play in mining coin maybe the regulation
should be a little different for you and
i'd rather have the policy developed
with with the you know the actual
industry participants uh in a way that
makes us the global leader now that
china's shutting down all those
you know those miners particularly the
ones that were using coal to burn
electricity this is a huge opportunity
for us and so we should take leadership
on sustainable bitcoin mining and other
you know
all the talk about ethereum and proof
proof of state and proof of work and all
the things that are going on there very
interesting
this sector requires the the regulator
to to
issue policy and once policies issued
let the competition begin because i'll
tell you a ton of capital is going to be
coming into the space we've seen in the
past in financial markets and this is a
little bit of a tangent but i was
reading about this over the weekend uh
an absolute um
drastic increase in america's position
in the global financial system the more
that we pursue deregulation that comes
with risks um but historically that has
been a positive
do we think that that framework applies
here as well where you basically need
some boundaries of hey this is really
really offside stuff this is really bad
you can't commit fraud no scams you know
all the stuff that is kind of common
sense but within that uh sandbox if you
will the less regulation the better from
innovation experimentation and really
pushing us forward or how would you look
at that with that historical context of
deregulation in america's place as the
leader on a global scale
yeah that's a good question here's the
way i look at it
you know there's billions of dollars
being invested in d5 all the different
payment solution opportunities all the
different things that could be done
around crypto assets there and that's
definitely where the puck is going and
i'm i've got several bets going on in
that space and pomp we haven't even
talked about nfts i mean that's i think
you know nfts
well so let's so let's just think about
that for a second if i'm the regulator
okay and i'm trying to i want innovation
they always want innovation they don't
want to you know stifle innovation maybe
the way i look at it and i'm just
speculating on what they might do is
they'll say okay let's do it this way if
there's an off-ramp and on-ramp with
fiat onto a d5 platform i gotta regulate
that because i'm taking regulated
currency
putting it onto a deregulated
decentralized platform but when it goes
back to fiat i want the tax reporting
was there a capital gain or loss on the
trade was there interest which is
interest income i want the regulatory
environment to apply to that even though
it's innovation so that i can get a 1099
or whatever i need to do for external
external regulators and i think if the
industry understands what those policies
are and what those rules are that'll
that'll accelerate innovation now when
it comes to nfts i'm going to make a
statement here that you may not believe
but i think that in the next five years
the market capitalization and of the nft
markets will exceed that of bitcoin
itself i really believe that because the
potential for all of these industries
that are you know dealing with physical
assets that want to credit give them
accreditation or give them providence or
sell nfts from that
is billions of dollars it's billions of
dollars from the mona lisa to my watch
collection and so i i look at it and say
to myself
which of those verticals should i become
an investor in and stake my claim and
the one that i'm starting with i haven't
talked much about this i don't think
i've ever mentioned to you is i'm
building a team around the watch
industry i mean
i've been i've been a watch collector
for
40 years i've got a massive build up in
that asset class and i want every single
every single one of my pieces
to have an nft associated with it and i
know all of the large collectors around
the world and i've talked to them and
they all want the same thing
it's a multi-billion dollar space
waiting to emerge in the next 24 months
and i'm going to lead the charge there
it's a very arrogant thing to say but
nobody
nobody knows the people i know
in terms of how to put this thing
together but that's just one tiny
vertical so here's my question and you
answered for me
is an nft of a watch
a security
or is it a piece of art
which is it i love you i wouldn't buy it
so i don't have to worry about that but
i know you
would buy it and i bet you you know what
the answer is my guess is uh they would
deem it a security only if the purchase
was made to try to
increase the price like you're buying it
specifically for the price appreciation
not for collection or wearing the watch
et cetera but how do you determine that
i don't know
well that's a very interesting answer
because that's the debate going on right
now because the same thing for art if
you buy a piece of art because let's
let's face it the nft i want to buy
let's say i know a collector named bill
and he's got a one-of-a-kind jp fp
journal watch that i can never have
because it's one of a kind and he's got
three nfts i'm a buyer i'd like to buy
that nft i don't know what it's going to
trade for it's going to get auctioned
but i bet you
in five years it's worth more now that's
no different than buying a warhol right
so i think we need to get policy on that
meanwhile back at the farm the reason i
want to get all my watches turned into
nfts is i've gone to the insurer and
they've said if you can go get them
accredited with an nft and authorized by
the original manufacturer and that
becomes a zero zero zero serial number
to your watch serial number
will give you a discount on your
insurance
why
i'm because what they're going to do is
say look if we can identify that watch
in perpetuity so when it's stolen we can
simply let the entire world know that if
you don't own that nft your watch is
stolen that takes a lot of pressure off
thieves and stealing watches if all the
world's one-of-a-kind watches were nft
with authorizations
who's going to buy a stolen one of a
kind unless they get the authorization
nft i wouldn't do it and it makes the
value of the stolen piece drop
dramatically that's why there's so much
rush to do this because right now even
the original papers for old
one-of-a-kind pieces
are forged you can't forge an nft
of a one-of-a-kind patek philippe you
just can't and that's why there's such
an interesting opportunity here all
right i hear you we got to get you a
watch that works you were late i had
everyone tweeted you late though
you are such a ball buster unbelievable
you never
do you want to know why i give you a
hard time only because i greatly greatly
respect your ability to change your mind
most people and we've had some of them
come on and they've been anti whatever
in the space and they get very stuck
there and they won't look at new
information they won't change their mind
so i will give you massive credit for
that i think you're probably the person
that i know that went from critic to the
most in in the entire space which is a
huge kudos to you two last questions and
then i'll let you go and you can walk in
the park behind you uh
first is dogecoin do you own any and
what do you think about all these folks
who are claiming that it is uh it's a
good medium of exchange
yeah you know it's um i don't own a um
you know it's and the reason is i i
really question its long-term asset
value but i'm not against it it's the
meme stock of crypto that's the way i
look at it it's been able to garner
tremendous amount of interest on social
media and i'm the first to admit today
over the last two years that there is a
direct correlation to market
capitalization of assets and social
media it's been proven over and over and
over again that if you can get a strong
group of followers or apes or whatever
you want to call them on reddit or on
robinhood you can actually elevate the
value of a company and for good reason
the more people know the story the more
they buy the stock and the more they
hold and stay along the stock and that's
why dogecoin's done so well it's become
a almost a character of itself but no i
don't own it it doesn't fit some of the
metrics i care about it's really easy to
understand why bitcoin is a property you
know you've got a diminishing number
left to be awarded and all the rest of
that just same with ethereum as a you
know form of payment in blockchain but
i'm having a hard time with dogecoin in
in an allocation i don't mind you know
having some fun with it on a wallet on a
phone but if i'm putting real dough into
it like a two or three percent
allocation
no i don't think so all right last
question every single person gets asked
you answered however you want
end of 2021 bitcoin price prediction
what do you got for us
i think we revisit and go through the
highs again um
the only thing that has me concerned is
everybody's made the assumption
um you know i'll stick with that but
here but the one thing i would say and i
i'm spending a lot of time talking to
institutions about this i'm on my way
uh to the uae uh in the middle east on
september 3rd over labor day weekend
this topic will definitely come up
everybody's assuming we're marching
towards the esg resolution i know a lot
of people that on coin now don't care
about it but it's the incremental buyer
that cares about it and and i think
every and they're making the assumption
of the next 24 months will resolve this
problem
if you want to see bitcoin crack that
hundred thousand we got to have a
solution and this is only my opinion
nobody else is okay i'm not putting it
out there anywhere else when i see that
larry think letter with the word bitcoin
innocent in there when he writes and
says i've you know i'm okay with bitcoin
mine sustainably
that's when you see the 100k price put
your seatbelt on then
yeah yeah i i'm not saying he's going to
do that i'm not saying he's going to do
that anytime soon but
i go right back to the beginning of our
conversation
the potential is so huge
even at a one percent allocation that is
why you should own bitcoin you have to
make the assumption the industry is
going to solve this problem and larry
will write that letter one day
and when that happens
katie bar the door
i love it if you like that video wait
you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe